the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
alright so welcome back today we
continue our look at musical interfaces
by examining the turn table and its
various contemporary formations in a
variety of controllers what we're going
to do is look at a little bit of the
history of the development of
turntablism we're going to talk about
some of the technologies involved
including turntables proper DJ mixers
look at a few scratch techniques will
cover a little bit about the development
of hip-hop extending back through the
Jamaican sound system tradition from
which it seems it came on too early
hip-hop innovators coming out of the
South Bronx in New York and onto a bit
of contemporary turntable practice at
the end will sort of all sort of argue
that what we see now going on is sort of
an abstraction of the turntable
interface extracting and abstracting out
the key control interface components of
the turntable and we'll see some
examples of that as we move forward so
brief reminder remember Thursday your
sonic systems projects we're going to
bring those in next week some prototypes
some draft sketches circuits code
pictures ideas bring something in be
prepared to show us something we'll
spend about five to ten minutes on each
person so have something to share and
that's the next thing coming up I have
almost all of your drafts in for the
project for the case study paper now
that you've turned that in try not to
stop thinking about it continue thinking
about it we would get a little bit of
time away from it but continue to do
your research i'll get you guys comments
back hopefully within a week or so and
that will give you more to work on as we
move forward questions comments
so one of your listings for today was a
track by people under the stairs this is
a hip-hop group out of Los Angeles who
speak about the folklore of hip-hop but
let's listen to a little bit of this
track to remind ourselves and in case
you don't
so in case you didn't catch all those
lyrics there a couple things to point
out what they're doing is talking about
the folklore of the foundations of
hip-hop it turns out that that's not
really folklore in that it's colored by
imagination it's actually it's part of
the real history of the development of
hip-hop they describe 40 days in the
studio struck water from a dots on top
of a mountain made of milk crates going
on people who still live in the folklore
of DJ Kool Herc BAM Grand Wizard
Theodore we're going to talk about all
those guys as we move forward today
we're going to sort of use this as a way
to frame our discussion of the
development of hip-hop before any Punk
with the keyboard could do it yo Apache
was the and every b-boy knew it we're
going to look at Apache one of the most
famous breaks of all turntable breaks
and finally yo its number one rap I'd
rather hear an 808 hand clap than that
we already know it that's a reference to
the famous 808 hand clap so before we go
on let's review our history of the
turntable of the phonograph remember
1877 Edison comes out with his cylinder
based recording mechanism 1880s 1887
Berliner releases his disk-based
gramophone the disc ultimately wins out
primarily because of why why did the
disc why don't we just went out yeah
record more and because it was bored
versus vertical wedges or edges what
we're basically evaded so that crews
door amplitude wasn't really effective
ism well there's a little bit more
regularity and doing the trend
transverse rather than the lateral cut
right but larger and less amplification
right we can we can regulate the
amplitude more better in the cutting of
the record but more importantly we can
make copies we can press copies super
easily of this flat disk and sell those
sell pre-recorded copies that's probably
the number one reason why the disk one
out because it was easier to reproduce
and we talked about that as sort of a
flattening of the dimensions of the
recording medium from three dimensions
on a cylinder to two dimensions on a
disc so by 1948 columbia releases the 33
in the third that's the large format LP
and that gets us back pretty much up to
where we've talked about the phonograph
and the gramophone so far 1969 technics
releases the SP 10 the first direct
drive turntable this a direct drive
mechanism turns out to be a fairly
important technical feature previous
turntables had used a belt mechanism and
the belt while effective tended to wear
out over time and uh sort of slow down
the rate wasn't always in cause as
constant and pose some other technical
problems with this direct drive
turntable the performance of the
turntable was a little bit more rigorous
and could handle a little bit more abuse
namely the kind of abuse that we see
with contemporary practice 1969 technics
releases of less expensive model the SP
1100 1972 they released the sl 1200 and
it's this turntable that really defines
the modern turntable practice if you go
find a DJ somewhere and you look at
their turntables probably six to eight
out of ten will be using this turntable
or some variation of it now they have
the SL 12 20 s 0 12
etc but the SL 12 is still the leading
model and in fact you'll hear hip-hop
artists refer to the SL 12 as the
turntable of choice this model allows
you to select different rotation speeds
depending if you have a 78 or 45 or a 33
and a third and it has this nice
variable speed adjustment slider here on
the right why would you want to very
smoothly vary the speed of playback slow
things down speed things up sort of fast
forward well yeah you could do that you
could okay that's that's one approach
yeah you can only just grab the needle
and throw it over here if your plane to
at the same time if you want to get them
to be about the same like page or if you
want them to be about same speed you
always just adjustments move it that's
right by adjusting the rotation speed
here and changing the rotation speed
good I was wondering if that was their
intent or of them is actually intended
to just be able to adjust for
fluctuations in life because in anime
need to do that if you want to get go
exactly 33 in third I think with the
direct drive motor and the their the
modern design they were able to pretty
regularly get the speed that they wanted
so i think the motivation at lee maybe
and certainly the most common use is to
match beats to match the tempo so that
you could slow down a track a little bit
and move into another track and match
the beats align the beats which leads to
the whole practice of beat matching
which used to be done manually by ear
but is more often done with software now
not 69 but late 70s early 80s I'm not
sure that's a good thing to to look at
this is a modder this isn't a 72 model
yeah yeah that's I mean that's a great
question to ask and something to look at
now combined with the modern SL style of
turntable DJ's often add a slip mat and
this slip mat is really the sort of
secret ingredient to modern turntable
technique it's simply a circle of felt
that goes under the record that permits
permits the record to spin independently
of the platter now this allows us to do
a number of things with our record the
so-called baby scratch is the most basic
scratch oops this is the transformer
either way we're going to look at a
couple scratches that don't require
using the mixer that just employ
manipulating the disc on the platter and
this is only possible because of the
felt of the slip mat or at least more
possible so this is the transformer oh
sorry this is a bed but this is not what
I won't know sorry let's go to the
phasers maybe this is written there we
go okay phases are just
same things lasers where you're holding
right so here are you showing the
technique where he's just adjusting the
rotation of the disk he's not doing
anything with the mixer he's just using
the ability for the disk to turn
independently of the platter we pull up
the baby this is the one I was going to
show before come on there we go as far
as scratching we learned here baby
scraps basically the easiest fresh to do
you know me better and 75 this house so
a very simple scratch again just being
able to manipulate the movement of the
record on the platter allows us to do
this there's this other one here called
the waves hope I have the right link
here which sort of adjust the rotation
in a quick and slow fashion
Wow
Wow what's interesting about that is the
movement of his hand looks like a cut
off like it's mapping the cut off
frequency at a low pass filter which is
kind of interesting I don't think it's
the movement of his hand that's making
this technique effective it's really
adjusting the playback speed in a smooth
fashion up and down that makes this
technique effective questions what's on
there um in that example um DJ's like
him and others sometimes use battle
records or records that are configured
with things really good for scratching
in that case that sounded sort of like a
vocal sample or somebody saying
something which often gives those good
sort of white noise sounds we'll hear
more examples of that in a little bit
now the DJ mixer is the other one of the
other really important components of the
turntable is set up and particularly the
cross fader the cross fader and the
toggle switch is found on a modern DJ
mixer I'll allow the turntable us to
apply variable amplitude envelopes to
the sound we've already looked at the
development of modular synthesizers we
can think of the cross fader and the
toggle switches the cross fader located
here and the toggle switch is located
here as a various ways of applying
amplitude envelopes to the sound the DJ
is capturing from the disc now there's a
wide range of other tools available on
the DJ mixer another important one is
the ability to listen to more sources
than are being played this is the often
described as sort of the cueing of a
record or the cue input what this allows
the DJ to do is play one record and then
play another record and listened to that
record in their headphones before they
play it out to the audience this leaves
the sort of stereotypical DJ pose of
having one head
on the Iran one cup of a headphone ear
on their head while doing something
they're queuing up the next record
they're listening to the next record
which may be a record or maybe a digital
audio file or maybe some other source
they're playing an existing record
listening to another record adjusting
where the records going to play maybe
adjusting the playback speed and doing
that all in the headphones before they
send that out to the main mix to the
house so the ability to queue up another
channel before sending it out is a
critical feature of DJ mixers now some
modern DJ mixers have a wide variety of
different effects some have delay some
have reverb somehow samplers some have
various other technologies for instance
this Mac ed 2 features an optical cross
fader which is advertised as never
changing its performance the cross fader
always performs the same way because
there's no friction there's other
designs that are using magnetic
technologies for the cross faders this
new mark DXM 09 has some beat
synchronized effects so it allows you to
set the tempo and then echoes and delays
and other effects are synchronized to
the beat which is a pretty nice feature
this new mark 5000 FX features an
integrated sampler which allows you to
while you're playing something simply
trigger a recording sample something and
then play it back either in Reverse or
forward later on which as you imagine
could offer some nice creative
techniques we already saw another
example where djs work with something
like an MPC sampler so seeing a
turntable next to an MPC is not uncommon
some DJ's might work with an external
sampler next to their turntable but we
do see some cases where the sampler is
integrated into the mixer this device is
very cool it seems to have been
discontinued but this vestax qfo has a
single turntable with a mixer built in
this provides a DJ to sort of be
solo set without a mixer it has the
essential functionality the cross fader
of a mixer built into the turntable so
that with just this and an mp3 player
you can put down a background check and
then scratch over this and have your
cross fader now working with the
turntable and the mixer is how most of
the turntable techniques that we think
of have come about I showed you guys
some examples the baby and the waves
that don't use the mixer these examples
use the mixer to create the various
scratching techniques so this is the one
I accidentally brought it before this is
the transformer as you might expect this
is named for making the type of
transformer transforming sound
Oh
so there we're basically taking a noise
source from the record and then applying
a variable amplitude envelope to that
noise source in a rhythmic fashion which
provides that's very nice Kwazii
transformer sound or maybe they used it
for the real transformers I'm not sure
yeah the chirp another technique check
this one out that makes use of the cross
fader magnificent jazzy jeff and you
need a stretch whistles on the hobart
anyway stress gonna treat me so so i
know you are get up the sound play and
you gotta turn it off right when it
place and just your hand backward in
light of your fashion thought about
things can anybody summarize what that
technique is there
we'll listen to a little bit more than
you can try again seems like it's
basically attitude modulation except or
modulating them to look it with a really
light attack well the attack is
gradually you can see that the attack of
the amplitude is gradual right you can
see them fading it in any other anybody
else on take a stab with describing this
with this technique is that does anybody
yeah it's basically links amplitude and
pitch so amplitude is faded in as the
record is sped up and then amplitude is
faded out as the record is slowed down
so those two parameters are linked and
that allows them to create this
distinctive sound right so amplitude and
the change in playback speed are linked
never hear that course DJ qbert is quite
good at this the crab gives us an
example of some of the really crazy
extended techniques that develop using
the cross fader if you've ever seen a
flamenco guitarist use all their fingers
this should remind you of this are used
to fingers typing so
instead of the tapping at will it's a
slide your fingers cross fader
electrostatic like things easy right
yeah and it was actually called scratch
because I specified because I know the
law right you guys could go home and do
that now right you just use your thumb
as a spring but that's a great example
of how the DJ mixer and particularly the
crossfader combined with the variable
playback of the turntable really
provides a wide range of different
sounds again we can think of it as
having variable playback speed and some
frequency modulation from the turntable
and we can think of the mixer is
providing a way for us to apply
envelopes and do amplitude modulation to
our sound questions get it design these
like two days turntables of the cross
fader is something just for queuing and
flying in air for party they made it
spitting later or the original cross
fader yeah yeah um it came out of I
think the need to want to have two
records and be able to continue have
continuous music reagents that long for
yeah we're going to get to some examples
of why that came about in a bit so when
we look at the development of hip-hop
and we look at the development of
turntablism it's essential for us to
look back to the foundations in jamaican
sound systems many of the modern
practices of turntablism of DJ culture
come out of the Jamaican traditions you
may not know that in the 50s and into
the 60s the Jamaicans developed a wide
range of different musical practices and
developed a very large and robust
recording studio system where there are
numerous studios there were numerous
independent Jamaican releases not only
of
but a wide variety of other musical
genres the genres that we are concerned
about come out of a tradition from these
things called sound systems now you may
think of a sound system as a sort of
boom box or something you buy at the
store that's essentially what these were
but at the time in Jamaica not everybody
had access to turn tables or amplifiers
and speakers so those that did did
started to hold parties and they would
have a sound system a turntable and
speakers an amplifier and would use
these as sort of community record
players people would get together and
dance have fun have a party and this
really led to the culture of the person
who ran the sound system being in charge
of providing the music being in charge
of running the party being in charge of
selecting the music the DJ's even began
to be known as selectors because they
would select the music being played
Clement Dodd aka coxon was credited with
the invention of this sound system
concept in the 1950s he established a
sound system called a downbeat sound
system and he later on went to open
studio one in Kingston in 1963 so we
have this sort of mixture of somebody
who starts off sort of as a performer as
kind of like a party organizer then
moving into the studio and becoming a
producer and a studio engineer working
with people like Bob Marley and others
now the Jamaican industry recording
industry was very active in the 1960s
they would often release b-sides of 45
rpm singles these b-sides very often
were instrumental versions of the a side
track and these be signs offered an
opportunity for people to remix and
experiment with these instrumental
tracks two types of experimentation went
on with these b-sides one involved
manipulating the sound on these records
and producing remixes and what we have
later began to call dub
another practice that came out of these
b-sides was vocalizations spoken word
over these instrumental tracks and many
credit the development of the spoken
word traditions often called toasting as
one of the foundations of modern hip hop
so musicians such as king tubby would
take either these instrumental b-sides
or four channel source tracks and remix
them and using basic studio processors
available at the time things like reverb
echo machines and the like often things
as simple as variable low-pass and
high-pass filters they would remix tunes
and often manipulate the vocals
manipulate the instruments in the way
that create these instrumental tunes
that we know as dub one of the pieces we
listen to for today's class 555 dub
street is a collaboration between
Augustus Pablo and King Tubby pablo was
known for his performance on what
instrument was that in this piece is it
up there the melodica an instrument
where you blow air into a small little
keyboard that allows you to control the
amplitude with your mouth and change
pitch with your fingers Augustus Pablo
performed on the melodica on produced
hole recordings and in this track King
Tubby comes in and sort of remix and
modifies this track on top of all of
that let's listen to a little bit of
this
okay right there what did we just hear
there yeah that's the melodica entrance
but did the melodica sound normal what
was going on some feedback a delay
there's like a delay that has a high
feedback level that's making it sort of
you hear an initial sound and then it
sort of continues into a constant
texture let's listen to that again
that's probably one of the most
signature sounds of dub first we have a
beads of course but then this use of
delay and echo to smear a sound let's
listen to that again
right there um what we just heard there
can be done with basic studio equipment
you need a delay unit you need some
faders you send the signal to the delay
unit with a high feedback it starts the
feedback and produce that continuous
sound and then he dropped the source
signal the rest of the beat so we got
that very nice gesture where we had the
feedback going on of the melodica and
then the beat drops out the beat comes
back in a little anticipation and
response and say that again what are we
just here on the hi-hats there yeah yeah
moving the filters maybe a peak notch or
parametric filter or a low or high pass
filter with a high resonance moving
across the high hats to create that
change in Tambor another very common
technique
so Doug exploited these relatively
simple techniques of cutting between in
and out of parts using feedback and
delay using variable filters to create
really interesting instrumental music
that was one tradition that came out of
the Jamaican sound systems another is
this focus on taking an instrumental
track and doing something over that
instrumental track in the sound system
tradition the leaders of the sound
system would want to encourage people at
their party to have a good time and
often would start toasting or shouting
out to the audience as the music was
playing often these toast would be
rithmatist chance of some sort and as I
said before many people credit this as a
key development to the existence of
American hip-hop but more than the sound
system the key person that's often
looked to as connecting Jamaican sound
system traditions to American hip-hop is
DJ Kool Herc Clive Campbell if we think
back to the people under the stairs
track we started with people who still
live in the folklore of DJ Kool Herc the
first person they mentioned her moved to
the Bronx from Jamaica in the late 60s
and really transplanted this sound
system concept he began throwing parties
in the South Bronx he worked with an MC
coke larock who would do some of the
toasting and began experimenting with
using two turntables each with the same
recorded material this led him to
develop a technique that he called the
merry-go-round which allowed him to cut
back and forth between two excerpts from
the same record and extend the music for
the sake of dancing for the sake of the
party in an excellent interview with
Terry Gross from 2005 he describes this
technique and the
element of his practice in a detail
better than I can so let's listen to a
little bit of this you're such an
interesting figure in hip-hop you know
everyone who was there at the beginning
seems to agree that you started at all
but because you never recorded in some
ways we made more of a cult figure and
star
that's why I got people exclusive you
know so you can say goodbye to rid of
everybody on the record and it will come
to see we why don't you dare you so what
do you guys think impressions ideas
surprises and the engine blew Chris yeah
let's truth responsible for Sega he
really feels responsible for like you
know keeping people happy that's right
yeah his attitude about what's supposed
to go on at these at these meetings that
these parties isn't is different than we
think of many hip-hop or DJ performers
these days it's not about himself as
well it is you see the pride he has but
it's also about well he's a shepherd you
know this idea that he's really
concerned about getting people to have a
good time his attention to his audience
is what led to his interest in the
merry-go-round and the brakes what is he
talking about their this merry-go-round
technique ideas and these breaks first
of all what are these brakes
so I'm gonna keep saying that people had
their favorite parts of the songs that
they were able to dance here they have a
little special move and right do their
special move and so he just figured why
not repeat it over never ends he get
people back in the dancing play that
special move that's right the brakes
would be the instrumental break in a
tune a place where the vocals would drop
out in the rhythm section would come
forward these would generally be
relatively short four eight sixteen bars
relatively short parts with the rhythm
section would come forward and these
would have a little bit more energy and
her realize that this inspired people to
dance more so we developed the technique
to extend the brakes his technique was
to use two copies of the same record and
then while one was playing he could spin
the other back and play the other and
switch back and forth between two
records with the same material and
extend the break he called this the
merry-go-round technique this led to a
whole attention to these brakes and he
mentions a very important one called
Apache which is also mentioned by our
friends the people under the stairs in
their tracks so let's look at this the
whole inch of the length of the whole
interview there is is there it's really
a great interview so Apache every b-boy
knew it Apache probably the most famous
break of all breaks it has a long and
complicated history a study of the
history of Apache was done by an author
with by the name mattos called all roads
lead to Apache you can find the complete
article here on the history of this tune
is complex and comes from various
sources in the 1960s 1960 there were two
versions of this tune Apache that don't
bear much relation to what we think of
now is Apache but we can hear a little
bit of these
ever hear that melody before yeah so
that was one version by Bert weed and
Cliff Richard in the shadows that
another version closely related to that
version sorry it's hard to describe what
it is i mean there's this like yeah it's
hard to say what it is but you'll see
where it gets into hip hop in a second
so here we hear the same melody slightly
different rhythm section
now those were the sort of foundations
of Apache it was the incredible Bongo
band with their album Bongo rock that
provided the break that excited people
like Herc and so many others later on
you will hear the same melody there from
the 1960 tunes but here he adds this
Bongo rhythm section that caught a lot
of people's attention
you
there's the same melody
with that opening Bongo rhythm is the
thing that excited people so much so
surely after the Sugar Hill Gang
produces the first to put this in
something more like a hip-hop context
there's a melody
you
now of course whole study could be done
not only on the evolution of this tune
but the distance and complex
associations and references to ideas
about Native American culture which are
relevant in this discussion but we're
just focusing on this one peculiar Bongo
rhythm what's come back comes back again
and again future sound of london not a
hip hop group use it in this example
here it's a little sped up and there's
some other things going on there
and a very clear example from 2002 by
the roots which starts off right with
that Apache Bongo rhythm
so the incredible Bongo band one of the
most popular breaks there is another
popular break is often referred to as
they all men break this again was nicely
taken into a single context by the study
of someone this one was this guy Nate
Harrison on this idea of studying the
history of a break as looking at the
lineage of either a sample or a break i
think is a really interesting approach
to studying music he produced this
little audio documentary called can I
get an amen where he looks at this four
bar drum solo from this group called the
Winston's that was found on a track on
the b-side a relatively unknown tune
that sounded like this
so then we can really clearly hear the
break the part where the brass section
drops out and the rhythm section steps
forward does that B sound familiar to
anybody never hear something like that
maybe maybe all over the place the Nate
Harrison documentary nicely describes
the different ways that this was used
not only how it was used in its original
form but how it was chopped up sold and
commodified in various sampler libraries
and other tools that people bought and
rearranged some quick examples of this
beat different artist uses in different
ways some of the connections you suggest
or maybe a little bit more distant like
the idea of this beat i think is used
sometimes as much as the original beat
but we can hear a little bit of this in
straight out of Compton by nwa you are
now about to say
we can hear a bit of the first bar of
that feed Matt ronix king of the beats
there it is again shy FX here we see
that amen breaks out to be cut up and
rearranged a little bit that's also very
popular now Harrison goes as far to
suggest that that beat led to holes on
Rizzo music that use that style of beat
which gets a little bit more of a
distant connection but I think there's
something to be said for that approach
Harrison also points out that this
sample was sold in sample packs and
available commercially which leads to
all sorts of interesting questions about
copyright and has this nice example from
a Jeep commercial in California that
uses this beat to suggest i don't know
the rugged freedom of driving in your
Jeep to go skiing or something nothing
handles the winter msg four by four
except of course using now drink extreme
chairs in the background there
that's the sure they're not there's no
side now back to the people under the
stairs people who still live in the full
core DJ Kool Herc we talked about Herc
BAM is a reference to Afrika Bambaataa
we talked about Afrika Bambaataa earlier
um Grand Wizard Theodore grand was a
theater is often credited for inventing
the scratch and whether or not this is
true is hard to say but the story goes
that he was hanging out in his basement
listening to a record and his mom yelled
hey Grand Wizard uh I'm sure that's not
what she said ha Theodore turn that
music down so he grabbed the record
anyway and thus was invented the baby
scratch and that's what they say how the
scratch was invented of course Grand
Wizard Theodore extended this technique
with various variations of that scratch
I had made it into a rhythmic technique
now Grandmaster Flash provides us with
some really excellent examples of
scratching techniques he was known for
extending numerous techniques for
developing his own electronics he built
some basic electronics and some say that
he invented or at least refined the
cross fader itself um he like many
turntablist came up with names for his
techniques he describes something called
the quick mix theory or sometimes called
the back spin technique which is
actually very similar to Herc's
merry-go-round he also describes
techniques such as the punch phase where
he would drop in and out of a record to
sort of grab one sample from it his
well-known composition Adventures of
Grandmaster Flash on the Wheels of Steel
was one of our listening for this class
let's listen to a little bit of that
same to remind us
they are chosen for time so we've
already heard of switched between three
or four three or four different records
um he was also dropping in and out doing
that punch phase technique on I think
that was the queen example in another
interview with Terry Gross Grandmaster
Flash narrates his techniques as he
listens to this tune which provides us
with a really great view into what he
was doing here let's listen to this you
think my face you see you think
Padres fudge face
same boat ride to Salida get girls like
it's a good size cheap so catchy what a
row apache again cut it out cut it up
talking it in my face queen hello left
us in touch we'll see whose eyes some of
them gets
good size so there he's gone around in a
sort of circle starting with that good
times tune taking a little trip on these
different Tunes coming back to where he
started and this would all have been
done live so not only was he
manipulating his turntables he would
also be changing records queueing up the
records just the right spot and of
course having the timing and skill to
execute this all without flaw what
exactly secure record but I guess just
the right spot yeah well if we have a
mixer and we have headphones we can
listen ahead and get the record at the
right place but with the development of
the art of turntablism these djs would
start to know their record so well that
they would simply be able to see the
groove even kirk was talking about being
able to see the difference in the
grooves to know exactly where to put the
needle in the right spot at the right
time two tables one is playing record
often some DJ's may even use more than
two but with techniques such as the
merry-go-round and the like the idea of
having two turntables I think becomes
really widespread other questions now we
start to see the DJ take on the role of
a soloist that Grandmaster Flash on the
Wheels of Steel was nineteen eighty one
but that didn't completely spread this
idea of the DJ as a soloist and it's
with a Herbie Hancock's tune rocket with
DJ Grand mixer DST that we start to see
the turntable that start to take on the
role of a soloist this tune rocket was
tremendously popular one because it's a
good tune to it has excellent scratching
and very prominent soulistic scratching
and three had an outrageous video which
had uh well I can assure to you was just
look
okay no thanks
now you could write a whole essay on
this video um what are some interesting
things going on here any anything you
see on the top of your head and
rhythmically and yet the visual rhythm
is law would be like acoustic yeah the
visual rhythm I think that's one of the
key things is that the movement of the
automata if you will the mannequins and
the like is synchronized to the rhythm
and some of the cutting of the turntable
which sort of visualizes what's going on
in the turntable in a way that can that
people can grasp other things going on
than this you see any humans through the
TV right the only human you see is
Herbie Hancock in the distance on
achieve black and white TV sort of
removed and you have these mannequins
these androids and sort of taking over
you have this sort of removal of the
human which could be interpreted in a
wide range of different and he's VOE
coded also you can see that he has a
little it's going to be hard to find his
picture there's his hands computer you
can see he's got a little mic on I
encourage you to watch that whole video
it's it's great that video did a lot to
popularize the DJ and to allow people to
start to think of the turntable as a
solo instrument some people have tried
to transcribe what a turntable is does
and this has led to something an attempt
to this call the turntable this
transcription method this group has
produced some transcriptions of famous
DJ tunes which allow us to see a little
bit about what's going on
and if we look here we can see a
transcription of the solo from that very
tune from rocket we can hear a little
bit of the turntable solo in that Thun
let me see if I can find it here one
transcriptions rocket
so the way this works it shows the name
of the sample on the left so we can see
that he's cutting a scratching over the
word fresh and these lines represent
changes in pitch that happened over time
so time is represented on the x-axis the
y-axis is showing sort of the time it
takes to move the sample over that
duration let's look at this
bye
bye
so pretty cool huh now the traditional
criteria we use to evaluate music often
use ideas about motivic development
presentations of themes and variation
repetition contrast and forward movement
do we see any of those things in this
solo here like what I mean right which
is an elaboration of the drum rhythm but
it's like another sort of motivic thing
and we can see quite clearly transcribed
here that it comes at the beginning of
each of the four bar groups so we have a
very clear structure with an opening a
motive a little bit of variation at the
end good what other motives or ideas
repeat in this tune in their solo
we see this little repeated rub come
back again and again in different places
finally at the end and then in the
closing phrase we have some nice
variation where the expectations that
have been established so far this
opening motive is cut up and broken
which creates a little suspense a little
expectation for the final resolution at
the end this is all done with a
turntable and with scratching there are
some more transcriptions here all of
which are very cool there is also a bit
of Grandmaster Flash on the Wheels of
Steel we can look at this briefly to see
a little bit about how this works in
that last example we were transcribing
cases where there was only one sample
being used he was scratching over
basically one word here they're trying
to show the use of different sources and
we can see that he's going back and
forth between different sound sources in
the transcription here si si si si si si
there's our old friend Apache yeah
that's a good question i think it's yeah
something to look at ya so when he's
scratching here there was good times you
can see this very clearly so that the
transition the good times becomes very
clear worry sort of giving you a little
taste of it ahead of time yeah there's
more here there's some other
transcriptions on that website and
encourage you to check it out it's a
very nice approach and really helps you
see a lot of different things going on
there are many ways in which the
turntable or use in contemporary
practice we're going to look at two in
particular the first is probably the
most common where the turntable is used
in hip hop in combination or an
alternation with the drums and the
vocals as a sort of rhythmic element as
a sort of counter interjection between
the vocals and between the rhythm
section sometimes we see the turntable
take on a special role and the chorus of
a song whereas in Iraq or other popular
context the chorus would be filled by a
big sort of sing along in a hip-hop
track the chorus might simply be the DJ
scratching or manipulating some sort of
refrain let's listen to a little bit of
eric b and rakim i ain't no joke
music maybe so how's the turntable use
their did you hear the turntable chubby
Charlie writing out your new material oh
right well you have the main be probably
on a turntable but if the scratching
here is the key thing right there was it
I met in the [ __ ] engine Sam please
think over it could yeah those are go so
good that's a good idea maybe the horn
cut right there but how's it being used
in the larger musical context if you
have an idea I mean I was I agree with
gives you a little bit of in the full
sample right so sort of a preview like
we saw with the Grandmaster Flash track
other ideas it's really key sesame it's
like the response yeah it's sort of a
response and it's filling this gap after
the verse before it comes down to the
downbeat of the next phrase so it's sort
of a little rhythmic tension to push you
at the end of the phrase into the
downbeat of the next phrase he's getting
in right with the vocals drop away these
little scratches
[ __ ] ain't nothing to the chorus so
that's the weirdest thing so we hear
their the chorus being taken over by
this role of scratching instead of again
the sort of big unified singing portion
we typically associate with the course
we have the chorus replaced by DJ
scratching now for an example of some of
the most modern techniques I had you
guys listen to DJ babu DJ qbert DJ's
mellow a group called D styles doing a
tune from 2002 called felonious funk
let's listen to a little bit of this
so we heard they're probably two DJs
each taking solo breaks this is a solo
DJ tune and they're tuning this sort of
as a jazz context is a rhythm section
going on a rhythm a beat and then our
each taking solos over this beat can you
generalize about the techniques or the
muses what what musically is going on in
those in those passages there yeah the
main beat seems pretty constant it seems
like there they probably have one DJ
it's probably playing the beat and then
they're cutting up other things what are
they what are they using as their
scratch material some sort of vocal word
that's right and how is it musically
deployed did you guys notice what's
going on is it sound unified does it
sound musical do you hear a phrase does
it sound like a solo did it have
coherence or did it sound like it was
wandering just scratching and rubbing
all over the place oh you hear the
repetition and like special motif going
back for so it definitely had some
musical qualities yeah anybody else hear
anything in particular in this I think
this is a really great example because
in in many ways it shows what we've seen
many times in our look at music and
technology it shows an attention to an
economy of resources using a small bit
of something and extending it out and
manipulating it in a variety of ways on
the opening solo here after this little
part here
this whole passage from here to the end
of this phrase is all one phrase that
someone saying oh my god so as a woman
saying oh my god and the DJ is
scratching that one phrase with this
entire passage and in a way it's sort of
a game you start to hear the words come
out until finally at the end you hear it
very clearly the goddess transforms into
the melodic passage
so three words use as sonic and motivic
source carefully deployed built upon and
extended to create what I think is a
very coherent solo we here in the next
solo what is this what's the phrase
being cut up here say what everybody
here now say what again this economy of
resources that's using a small bit of
material as a source for an extended
composition is something we've seen time
and time again in many of the works that
we've looked at think of Huell Akane's
drip city a composition that used one
sample one taped piece of sound as a
source for the entire composition think
of the rigorous application of tape
techniques by by cage or others on this
idea of using a small bit of material
and extending it is so common in the
tradition of music and one that we see
here employed on the turntable now the
last thing we're going to look at is
what I consider the sort of abstraction
of the turntable pulling out the most
essential feature of the turntable and
as we talked about in the beginning the
most essential features seem to be the
ability to control the speed of a
rotating disk that combined with a mixer
that an a crossfader but this idea of a
rotating disk that somehow gives a
useful interface for controlling musical
time one reason the rotating disk is
useful for controlling musical time is
because it has momentum when you have a
rotating disk there's a very tactile
connection and you gradually and can
speed it up or slow it down it has a
sense of momentum because it's going so
that
forced to slow it down and if you let go
it gradually speeds up that issue of
momentum of rotation tied to musical
time is very important it's not found on
a digital audio file we can start and
stop a digital audio file there is no
sort of momentum to the playback of
digital audio unless of course we build
models that incorporate that so various
approaches have been proposed to sort of
keep this rotating disk this rotating
platter available on this technics sl d7
1200 this device seems to be
discontinued allowed you to enter a CD
into this slot here and the control
let's play back with the rotating disk
this is very much like the sl 1200
turntable it's the exact same platter
but the platter notice there's no tone
arm there's no record needle the platter
is controlling exclusively the playback
of the content fond on a disc another
approach this one by tascam the TTM one
uses a little component to ride on the
disc and track its motion that tracked
motion of the rotation of the disk again
incorporating any changes in playback
speed by the operator is used to provide
a control signal that works only with
their proprietary CD players found here
but this allows you to use the turntable
as a controller for the playback of
stored digital audio expensive well and
also probably air prone right because
you can imagine the contact here may not
be very reliable this wheel might slip
they still make this product the
approach that has found the most
widespread use goes into various names
it's now owned by the rain corporation
is called Serato Scratch there's various
versions of this but the way that this
system works is you use your
conventional turntables that you've
invested hundreds of dollars in you use
your mixer which you've already invested
a lot of money in but instead of playing
records that have music on them you play
records that have a specially encoded
control signal this control signal is
tracked out of the output of the
turntables by the computer the control
signal is formatted in a way such that
variations in playback speed which may
result by you changing the the playback
speed with a slider or by scratching are
captured by the computer and can be
applied to any digital audio file so
this allows you to use your old
turntables as a control surface for
digital audio files stored on your
computer in any format this literally
lets you scratch your mp3's yeah problem
we're both is we're out
yes but I think it's more it's probably
more accurate and these control records
are relatively inexpensive and probably
last as long as any record does so it
may not be a major concern I don't but
that's a really interesting thing to
look at I don't also know exactly what
how the control signal is encoded we
could imagine a couple of ways it could
be some sort of binary spacing of clicks
that it looks at how close the clicks
get together they might try another
approach but it's interesting to think
about how that system works on the
control software for this is fantastic
it not only shows you the waveforms
coming through which makes it easy to
beat match by matching up the lines here
it lets you cue up other songs for each
virtual turntable and do a lot of other
fun things if you go to guitar center go
to the DJ section you can try this out
it's quite a bit of fun now that's
expensive because you still have to have
real turntables and a lot of DJ's really
like this approach because they can use
their existing turntables furthermore if
they want to combine a vinyl disc on one
turntable and a digital audio file on
another they can mix and match with the
serato scratch system other sort of
hybrid systems are things like this
numark ns7 which combines notice these
are 78 size discs which combines this
notice there's also no tonearm here so
this device provides a sort of
integrated control where you can control
the playback speed with these discs the
mixer and other tools are built in but
again it's all controlling digital audio
stored on the computer here presumably
the actual movement of the platter is
what is used to control the playback
speed of the digital audio but this
again is another approach of sort of
abstracting out this essential feature
of momentum based playback model so I
like to look at this where we've looked
at here as sort of a trajectory from
first
version taking a device that was not
intended to be used as a sole elastic
instrument and we're finding the number
of techniques out of this process of
corrosion and then now that that sort of
solidified what would the term be the
biker might give to that sort of the
scratching techniques sort of reach a
sense of closure we see a sort of next
stage where now the essential features
of the turntable are being abstracted
pulled out and made into a number of
devices that provide similar control but
a totally different playback Mehcad
mechanism that is reading digital audio
off of a computer or other stored data
ideas what other can you imagine other
types of momentum based controllers we
might have if we imagine what the next
stage will people continue to use things
like cerato to with conventional
turntables or might we imagine other
interfaces that will allow djs to do
what they've done for the last 30 or 40
years but in alternative ways of like
surface tables they could just sort of
showed images then work on that that's
true i mean we do see this interest in
touch screens and the like and you could
visualize the screen but i think a
problem there would be that you don't
have momentum you can't feel the speed
and i think that's a very important
feature of turntablism and i think
that's something that's retained in the
abstractions that we see there I think
that and that just really illustrates a
good point because there's something in
the contact in that sense of momentum of
having a physically spinning disc that
seems to be really important to
turntable practically
again with CD DJ interfaces don't
actually some don't rotate yeah there
are some that don't rotate they just
give you a big button that you can move
but it doesn't seem like DJ's are really
attracted to those the ones that DJ seem
to be attracted are the ones that
actually represent playback time in some
sort of rotational sets other ideas what
a DJ hero DJ hero how does that work
it's one turntable a crossfader the
turntable with buttons point and you
stretch like two outer buttons you hold
them down while scratching and that's
how you like what you do you have to
move the cross fader to succeed you have
done with the cross fader to the three
positions or whatever and then but the
weird thing with the scratch means that
again it doesn't spin or anything yeah
lightweight turntable and it's hard to
keep the press a button and scratch or
thing at the same time
that's great well you can all play DJ
hero or just go to guitar center and try
out Serato Scratch it's really fun great
I'll see you guys next time
you